welcome to this video mara mara anguish
okay great master let's see I know
information who that is yeah czech
republic let's see a Kalashnikov that i
keep trying out but still had failed to
really look the look of the theorem ship
III in this position okay so night g5 we
should be success quite obviously the
idea
hmm i wonder if i go Knight f6 I play
Knights you phone okay I should really
just play a move and we should be six
yeah maybe that wasn't so Grady is
coming with c4 that's not not really
nice looking very very uncomfortable
position here yeah I cannot take and
before is really not what I want to do
yeah maybe maybe it's so bearable but
not not really what I intended to do
well this this however still just looks
quite okay right hmm
hmm maybe I want us do i switch that off
okay so let's see how do I trade maybe
with maybe I get in Bishop g5 if that
would be nice hmm but the d6 porn is
weekend there is no way around that yeah
Bishop g5 TX night x he just might play
93 and ask me how I'm protecting this
pawn yeah a simple question but a good
one here Queen B 6 is this a move I
didn't plan any of that so if I'm not
losing the pawn this is pure luck we'd
be 6 quindi 6 look the eighth hmm
hmm all night on Creedy six i also might
have 94 as a as a trick but that's not
really that great run okay yeah he can
maybe take it roop the 85
if he's not taking it right away ok King
edge 1 also might be a move actually now
by then 96 hmm ok so c5 is going to come
no ah this tactic oh nice yeah I was
only thinking about 95 yeah that's a
piece ok blauer resides yeah that means
I'm really in trouble here with the pawn
Jim yeah then probably ashed I cannot
really I cannot play 95 then simply I
have to start with Bishop g5 now that
that's what i need to do ads it's more
precise this 95 yeah it kind of belongs
in this position but it was just wrongly
timed this is this is kind of ok for me
just normal normal position him here I'm
just I'm just a tattoo too late i am i'm
just too late with a camera in d6 yeah
the comp wants to play weird stuff Queen
d7 route d8 but at least it keeps the
pawn and here you're understandably I'm
in trouble yeah this is just down just
bad empty cig zhang's I have no way to
protect it and even there are this kind
of thing is just not now i can take here
but it's not leading to anything
okay I overlooked 26 I did some I have
to have to play 96 and try to fight here
which is kind of possible I were pawn
down but he's got this very bad bishop
on e2 nah it's not attractive but it was
some still something to try but I was
already so irritated that I even
overlooked 26 okay yeah it was a matter
of timing and Bishop g5 was just
stronger I cannot I don't have the time
can you actually avoid it but then then
I really do this kind of thing now that
that's a fairly normal position for this
opening okay thanks for watching